المترجم: Bardise ELDeeb
المدقّق: Aya AlAjjan
أمتحمسون لمعرفة
المتحدث القادم؟
أنا متحمسة
متحدثنا القادم ممثل مسرحي
ومقدم برامج, بالتأكيد قد رأيتموه
شكله مألوف, ربما رأيتموه في قتاة أجيال
طفل بدأت موهبته من قبل دخوله إلى المدرسة
والآن هو عضو في جمعية الثقافة والفنون
ونسيت أن تقول إنه أيضا عضو في فريق
"طفولة آمنة"
رحبوا معنا بأصغر طفل موجود معنا اليوم
"قصورة الزارع"
صفقوا
السلام عليكم
أنا اسمي قصورة الزارع
عمري ثمان سنوات
سأتكلم عن موضوع "طفولة آمنة"
أنا أعرف واجباتي كطفل
أنا منتظم في المدرسة
أحل واجباتي, أحصل على أعلى الدرجات
أساعد والدي في المنزل
أحافظ على نظافة غرفتي, ونظاقتي الشخصية
أنا أعطيت واجباتي, أعطوني حقوقي
أحتاج إلى الاهتمام
أحتاج أن تشاهدوني في استخدامي لشبكة
الانترنت
أعطوني فرصة لإظهار موهبتي
أن تعاملوني بلطف
تتحاوروا معي وتتناقشوا
لأني أنا طفل ومن حقي أن أخطئ
وشكراً